Donald Trump appeared in court today in
Washington D.C he pleaded not guilty to
the conspiracy charges he's been
threatened with remand into custody
pre-trial confinement if he communicates
with any of the Witnesses in the case he
agreed to these terms and then he
carried on his merry way and I will just
say in the context of this story the
fact that they did not remind Trump into
custody proves it is a political sham
because anybody who did anything I mean
you know you know what no no not even
anything near let's if you stole a
diamond necklace and you owned a bunch
of jets they'd be like okay this dude's
a Flight Risk and you have buildings in
foreign countries you have properties
all over the world you own Golf Resorts
they'd be like this guy's a Flight Risk
they're accusing Donald Trump of trying
to overthrow the U.S government an
Insurrection a conspiracy to defraud the
US and they're like you're free to go
good sir just you know come back when we
need you they don't seriously think this
man did anything wrong it's political